[Music]
Water scarcity will be a global issue of
critical importance in the 21st
century and ensuring safe drinking water
and water for farming will be an
enormous challenge.
[Music]
Low and irregular rainfall patterns are
not the only reasons for
drought. Irresponsible and unplanned
development, environmental damage are
worsening the problem.
[Music]
Climate change is causing weather
patterns to shift leading to unseasonal
rains, hail storms, dust storms,
excessive rainfall, rising temperatures
and frequent droughts.
Natural water resources are drying up or
disappearing at an alarming rate even in
regions that receive nearly 200 mm of
rainfall. Take Maharashtra as an
example. 11% of the cultivable land
receives 50% of the available water. Out
of 225 lakh hectares of arable land in
the state, 40% is prone to
drought and 7% is prone to floods.
Experts estimate that a farmer needs at
least 3,000 cubic meters of water per
hectare to grow one karif crop and one
irrigated
crop. As a result, farmers rely on bore
wells. However, excessive use of
groundwater has significantly reduced
the water availability underground.
Groundwater levels have dropped so much
that it is common to find water only 500
to 1,000 ft below the
surface. This drastic decline has
disrupted natural springs and negatively
affected groundwater temperature.
Although people are now more aware of
these
issues, very few act to prevent the
looming
crisis. But there are notable
exceptions just like Romesh Karmmar, a
retired army officer from Junar,
Maharashtra.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
In
2021, Romesh decided to give back to
nature on his
birthday by digging water absorption
pits.
on the Dhan Kale Mountain near Junar
[Music]
city. Tirelessly working as a
conservationist with the support of his
dedicated wife
Swati, this couple has dug 70 soaked
pits to recharge groundwater.
These pits spanning 412
m absorb an impressive 8 lakh l of water
during a single
rainfall. A practice that they have
continued since 2021.
[Music]
Soak pits are a traditional cost
effective method for sustainable water
management.
They help water seep into water table
beneath the
soil. These pits store rainwater which
then replenishes the groundwater.
Continuous cut trenches are dug out 1 to
2 m or even lesser 1 to 2 ft and the
excavated soil is collected on the down
slope of the trench. Continuous control
trenches help in reduce runoff, help
conserve the soil and reduce the speed
of onland flow of water. If there are
large quantities of water then the soil
water actually percolates into the
groundwater and therefore CCTS are also
considered as structures that help in
improving the groundwater of the
area. The Karmmade couple didn't stop
there. They created an oxygen park by
planting over 500 trees on the same
mountain with public
support. These trees not only produce
clean
air but also protect the environment by
preventing soil erosion.
[Music]
Romesh's environmental efforts go beyond
soak pits and tree
[Music]
planting. He has also addressed the
problem of
wildfires which have become more
frequent due to global warming.
To combat the wildfires, he cuts the dry
grass into small patches and creates
barriers that reduces the spread of
fires during hot seasons and droughts.
[Music]
This approach is an innovative and
effective way to prevent wildfires from
spreading across large
areas. Romesh's work demonstrates how
ideas, determination, and relentless
effort can make a real
difference. Their initiatives serve as
an shining example of what can be
achieved through dedication and vision.
Romesh's dedication to water
conservation has led him to restore
neglected stepwells and tanks in the
Junar
[Music]
Taluca.
for these forgotten water
resources called as
Baravs are hidden in plain
sight but are now being revived with the
help of local youth who clear the
vegetation, remove the silt and repair
the structures.
In today's fastpaced world where people
rarely dedicate time to nature without
expecting anything in
return, individuals like Romesh and
Swati are unique and truly a blessing.
While most people focus on themselves,
Romesh and Swati stand apart as someone
who nurture
nature which in turn gives
[Music]
generously.
Southern foreignch.
[Music]
Several individuals have contributed not
only to create vast areas of continuous
control trenches in aforestated areas or
in barren areas, but they have also
joined hands with government officials
and with forest department to create
unique ecological niches in the upland
of
Maharashtra. Their efforts in water
conservation, tree planting,
environmental protection and social
service have earned many awards
including recognition from the
government of Maharashtra and the forest
department.
Foreign speech. Foreign speech. Foreign
speech.
It is the perseverance of selfless
individuals like Romesh and Swati that
makes the world a better place.
We should all strive to conserve water
just as they do for the sake of our
future
generations. Water is the greatest gift
of nature to humanity and we must
protect each drop.
[Music]